[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and it's time to put a
smile on that face with our first proper
look at jared leto's joker in zack
snyder's justice league
it's time to let go of the the gangster
pimp
leto version of the character as we now
have a
far more terrifying one that feels much
more engaging than what's come before
it was said that leto's version of the
character the majority of it was left on
the cutting room floor
and it did feel like he was done a
massive disservice with the version of
the suicide squad that we got
now this looks absolutely terrifying i
love how he's sort of a road weary
version of the character with
long hair smudged makeup and what i
think is
a bloody apron or overalls either way it
looks
it looks absolutely terrifying and it
feels quite in line with the crow
now if you cast your mind back to you a
couple of weeks ago you will remember
that we got a look at
ben affleck's nightmare version of the
character and he seems to be standing in
the same place that leto's version is
now
we've long asked for a meeting between
the pair and it seems like we're finally
getting it in what is going to be the
extended and additional scenes in zack
snyder's justice league
we're going to be breaking it all down
but if this is your first time here then
i'd massively appreciate the thumbs up
and also make sure you subscribe to the
channel for videos like this each and
every day
we're also giving away three free copies
of the marvel phase three 4k box set but
i'll talk about how you can get your
hands on that more towards the end of
the video
now we do know that there's going to be
an extra scene at the end of zack
snyder's justice league
and though it has been said by walter
hamada that this
is a cul-de-sac personally i'm thinking
it's a cul-de-sac
and it's gonna open the door for a lot
more opportunities
for snyder to get so many actors back
involved such as ben
affleck jared leto joe manchinello and
amber heard
it just seems to be setting up so many
avenues that they can go with it
and obviously seeing this look it's got
fans absolutely over the moon
i'm someone who didn't really like jared
leto's version of the character that
much
and i felt that the whacking phoenix one
that followed him
and the heath ledger one that preceded
him were much better than what we got in
in his vision i don't really feel like
that's his fault though and he's an
absolutely terrific actor
so it is great that he's getting the
chance to revive the role once more
now it is rumored that this moment is
actually taking place
five years after the events of justice
league and that it will be in the
war-torn environment that was shown in
batman v
superman it's also featured in the
trailer for justice league
so it does make a lot of sense that this
is the direction that they're going
the joker's card was also present there
too and it seems like he's going to be a
big player in this moment
i have heard that batman and the joker
are actually going to team up in order
to defeat darkseid
but whether that comes true or not we
don't know yet however this does look
amazing and it seems like we'll finally
be getting the conflict that batman and
the joker deserve
now the film is gonna be a four-hour
epic and it's set to release on march
18th on hbo max
and though we don't know how that's
going to be released to the rest of the
world
it will finally make it out there this
seems like one of the most unhinged
versions that's ever been put to film
and it does remind me a lot of the crows
simply because of the
the long black hair and this shadow
around the eyes
i love that he's had laser surgery to
remove those tattoos
and the scars on his face makes me want
to know how
he how he got those scars what anyway
as i'm sure you can tell i'm absolutely
over the moon with this look
and i've never been more hyped for a
film that's so so close
we've been waiting since 2017 for this
and to know that we're getting it next
month
it just feels absolutely amazing now
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the look in the comments section
below
so make sure you let me know and as a
thank you for interacting with this
video you'll be entered into a prize
draw on the 28th of february
in which we're giving away three copies
of the marvel phase 3 4k box set to our
subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video drop a
comment below and make sure you
subscribe with notifications on
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the footage that was recently released
on the film
and also the trailers from the super
bowl which will be linked on screen
right now
without the way thank you for sitting
through the video i've been paul
i'll see you next time take care peace